i haven't felt like this for somebody in
such a short amount of time
i really want to open up to him but it's
scary to open the door to being
vulnerable and possibly rejected what'd
you think about
today um my grandparents asked me how to
farm i've never been on it but i was
like oh
okay i can finally understand like what
my grandparents are going through
i think there's just something about you
like i'm super excited
um i literally get like the biggest
smile on my face when i'm around you
but i also want to be as open with you
obviously through this process and you
want a wife
and you want a family and you know i
want those things too
but if i were to
have a family there is a really strong
possibility
you know that my kids would be deaf
my birth dad did walk out on my mom
and my sister right after we got our
cochlear implants
when you have you know what should have
been one of the most
important people in your life you know
walk out hard not to feel like
you know if i fully open up myself to
somebody
are they gonna do the same thing god
tell you something
[Music]
you